[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Hey, it's Natalie again.
Thank you so much for
tuning into the Livestream.
I have the extreme
honor of sitting here
with Kelly Shuster.
She's an Android
developer for iTriage.
And I'm excited to have
you meet her and have
her talk about her work.
Welcome, Kelly.
KELLY SHUSTER: Thank you
so much for having me.
I'm honored to be here.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So
tell me a little bit,
how did you get into
the technology industry?
I think you had mentioned
harmware-- or not harmware--
firmware, hardware,
mixing the two.
KELLY SHUSTER: Yes.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Tell
me a little bit about it.
KELLY SHUSTER: Sure.
So I never really
thought that I was
going to be a tech
person in my career.
So when I was
younger, I started out
with a lot of
different interests.
I did theater.
I loved reading.
I loved history.
And I also loved
math and science,
but they were just like
these extra things.
But I had this intense
curiosity about computers.
I remember staring at
my parents' computer
and just being obsessed.
Like, what is going on?
I know there are people in the
world that know how this works.
It's not magic, and I
have to figure it out.
So I watched this movie with
my sister-- "Antitrust."
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
I think you told me
it was "Hackers" because
that's how-- "Hackers,"
for me, that's what it was.
KELLY SHUSTER: Really?
That's awesome.
Yay for Hollywood
getting us into tech.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Which is rare.
KELLY SHUSTER: Yes.
Yes.
Exactly.
So there's this scene
where he's at the daycare,
and he hacks into the system
through the daycare computer.
And I became obsessed
with the idea, like,
could you really do that, or
was that a Hollywood thing?
So that got me going
on this tech area.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
[INAUDIBLE] hacking.
KELLY SHUSTER: Yeah.
Like, could you really do this?
Yeah.
And when I went into
college, I actually
was a political science major.
And I had to take a science
for political science.
And so I opted to take physics.
And my adviser was
like, no, no, no, you're
supposed to take meteorology
or intro to astronomy--
the "easy sciences."
Like, no, I really like physics.
It's so fun.
So then towards the end
of my physics class,
I realized I was
so depressed that I
was going to be done
with math and science.
So I was like, why don't I
just switch to engineering?
So I switched over to
electrical engineering.
And I just loved it.
It was much fun.
And I learned how
computers work finally.
And it was awesome.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
[INAUDIBLE] from there.
KELLY SHUSTER: Yes, exactly.
I felt like I hit a niche.
And I was just in
my stride, yeah.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So
tell me, so now you're
an Android developer.
KELLY SHUSTER: Yes.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: And
you're working at iTriage.
And you were telling me
you're the accessibility lead.
KELLY SHUSTER: Mm-hm.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Talk to me a little bit
about what you're solving
for and maybe some
of the challenges that you
faced in your current role.
KELLY SHUSTER: Sure.
OK.
So at iTriage I'm working on a
new app for Aetna's new member
experience.
So you can check claims or
doctors or things like that.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
I would love that.
KELLY SHUSTER: Yeah, it's
going to be so awesome.
I can't wait.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: It
makes health care easier.
KELLY SHUSTER: Yes, exactly.
Super easy.
Information when you want it.
And it's going to be awesome.
And so one of the big
pieces that I'm personally
passionate about is
developing accessible apps
so that all people can use it.
And we're really focused
on vision impairment.
So I'm an Android developer, so
I'm doing Android for the app.
But I'm also the accessibility
lead for web and iOS as well.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
So you're not busy.
KELLY SHUSTER: Not
in the slightest.
So it's really cool.
I get to work with this
group called the Blind
Institute of Technology.
And they're a
nonprofit group run
by an engineer and all
these tech savvy people
that also happen to be blind.
And they come in and
they test our app.
And I work with them to
understand, like, what
can we do from a
programming perspective
to fix these issues?
And I help the
developers on our team
about what are the
tips and tricks
for coding, for web,
iOS, and Android
that they can implement.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
It's cool user testing.
KELLY SHUSTER: Very cool, yeah.
And they have their
own set of standards.
It's not tied to
specific regulations,
but it's tied to
actual usability.
Because a lot of the
official regulations,
you can check off all the boxes
but still not have a great user
experience.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Right.
No, I mean, you're
putting the user first.
And I think that's what's
really important in developing
new technology is
you don't necessarily
have to start from scratch.
Like, know your users.
And so it sounds like you guys
are doing a great job talking
to the community.
And from there, you're
getting the insights
to build for them
with them in mind.
KELLY SHUSTER: Exactly.
Because I feel like I read
through the documentation
about accessibility, but it
wasn't really until I actually
got to know them as
users that I was like,
oh, I was thinking
about that wrong.
So it's really cool.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: No,
that's really great.
And so, what would
you say a challenge
was and a creative solution
that you implemented
in your current work?
KELLY SHUSTER: As far
as accessibility goes,
I think a lot of it is in
terms of not really knowing
exactly how the screen reader's
going to read things out,
and so finding ways to set
content descriptions on layouts
as opposed to on specific views.
But outside of
accessibility, the greater
technical challenges,
we had a challenge
with the back end solution.
So when we were looking at all
the schedule-- and our back end
is being developed
by another team,
and we're not their
only stakeholder.
And so they were on
this longer timeline.
So we were like, shoot.
We're not going
to get everything
in time for us to be able
to put the app together.
So my manager came up with this
brilliant solution about, well,
why don't we just have these
different networking modes?
And we can build out
these fake APIs for us
as we develop our
app internally.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Wow.
Cool.
KELLY SHUSTER: Yeah.
And then as we start getting
the services delivered to us,
we can just flip a switch.
I was like, ah, this
is such a cool idea.
So we had to be really strict
about separating model view
controller in our app.
And every platform did this.
We pushed the logic
of switching modes
to the lowest layer of
the networking library.
And we just started integrating
the real back end services.
And it was so awesome,
because we literally just
had to new base URL and then
maybe a little bit of tweaking
with JSON parsing,
and it just works.
And it's so cool.
And there's an Easter egg
menu in our alpha channels.
So people can switch
between this fake API
mode and the real
API mode, which
is incredible for the
business stakeholders,
because it's super hard to demo
back end services to people
that are really high
up in the companies
because there's that huge
technical gap of knowledge.
But if they have the
app in their hands
and they can toggle back
and forth with the modes,
they can easily see the progress
of the back end services.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
And so from all of
this, you're incredibly
passionate about
technology, right?
What I love about--
so you're not only
just doing incredible
work at iTriage,
you're also out leading
and helping more women,
specifically get
into technology.
And so you're also one of the
founders and leaders of Women
Who Code Denver.
KELLY SHUSTER: Exactly.
Yeah.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So what
is that community like,
and why is it important?
KELLY SHUSTER: Oh my gosh.
The community is awesome.
So I started out in hardware,
like we were talking before,
with electrical engineering.
And a few years
ago, I transitioned
into Android development.
And during that time, I
just found meetup.com.
And I was like, this is amazing.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
[INAUDIBLE] them, too.
KELLY SHUSTER: Oh my gosh.
It was so great.
So I just went
through and signed up
for every tech meetup.
And I was like, oh, Women
Who Code, that sounds cool.
And I remember, I went to
my first meetup for Women
Who Code.
It was a Ruby study group.
And I wasn't a huge
Ruby person, but I was
like, oh, it sounds like fun.
And I show up.
And there are all these
women literally just sitting
around hacking and programming.
And it was indescribable.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: It's
like the idea of where
we both started was real.
It wasn't just Hollywood.
It was women actually doing
what we always wanted to do.
KELLY SHUSTER: Exactly.
And I didn't even
realize I'd never
programmed with more
than one woman before.
And I was like, wow.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: And
that's really common.
KELLY SHUSTER: Yeah.
And I didn't really realize I
was missing anything in my life
until I went.
And I was like, oh,
this is so cool.
I want to do this all the time.
So I started going
to their meetups.
And they had a lot of
really good tech talks.
And the woman that
was leading Denver
was actually moving
to Boulder, I think.
And so she was going to
do the Boulder stuff.
And the position opened up.
And she was like,
do you want to lead?
We need someone to lead it.
And I was like, I would love to.
The women that I meet
here are phenomenal.
And it's really cool, too.
With the [INAUDIBLE] ability
and all these things,
I'm interested in the
idea of a full stack
or a multi-platform
knowledge, which
is amazing because in the
Women Who Code community, we've
got Java people, we've got iOS,
Android, Ruby on Rails, Scala.
You name it, they're
here in my group.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: And so
when you go to the meetups,
you don't necessarily
just even have
to work on what you're
working on at iTriage.
You can work on
personal projects.
Do you have personal
projects that you're
working on outside
of your current work?
KELLY SHUSTER: Yeah, actually.
So I have one little app.
It's called Should I Buy It.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: This
already sounds dangerous.
KELLY SHUSTER: Yes.
Yes.
So I'm a personal finance geek.
And I like to help people make
smart financial decisions.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
I like shopping.
KELLY SHUSTER: Yes.
OK.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: I'm
really good at spending money.
I need to learn how to save it.
KELLY SHUSTER: This app
might help you then.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: OK.
KELLY SHUSTER: You put in
what you're going to buy
and how often you think
you're going to buy it,
and it will tell you if you had
invested the money instead, how
much you'd have after 10 years.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Yeah, I need this.
KELLY SHUSTER: Yes.
It's awesome.
It is available in Android.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: It is?
It's on the Play Store?
KELLY SHUSTER: It's
on the Play Store.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: OK.
So tell me again,
what is it called?
KELLY SHUSTER: Should I Buy It.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Should I Buy It.
KELLY SHUSTER: It's
got a little green logo
with a scale of a bag of
money or a cup of coffee.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: All right.
KELLY SHUSTER: Yeah.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: I'm
going to start saving
more money because of that app.
KELLY SHUSTER: Cool.
Cool.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
So, again, I'm
really thankful that you made
time to come and visit us
today.
You're clearly doing incredible
work for accessibility
at iTriage and you're leading
Women Who Code Denver.
It sounds like you don't
really have spare time,
but then you've created
this awesome app.
So anyways, I'll look forward
to hearing more innovations
that you're creating
in the future.
Thank you so much
for making the time--
KELLY SHUSTER:
Thank you so much.
This was awesome.
Thanks.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Thanks.